[Música]
llegamos a la información económica aquí
en directo América me acompaña nuestro
compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge vamos a
empezar hablando de la economía porque
pese a la gente inflación que hay los
estadounidenses en agosto consumieron
más que en julio el dato de la ventas
minoristas que subieron un 0,3% respecto
a Julio y fue es una cifra bastante
inesperada el dato lo presentó el jueves
en el departamento de comercio Y es que
excluyendo el negocio de la gasolinera
las ventas subieron un 0,8% también 8 de
las 13 categorías de venta al por menor
crecieron el mes pasado incluido Un
aumento de las ventas en los
concesionarios de automóviles las ventas
de compras en los concesionarios de
vehículos y piezas de recambio aumentar
un 2,8% el mes pasado el informe es un
reflejo de la resistencia de los
compradores la cifras tampoco se ajustan
a la inflación A diferencia de muchos
otros informes gubernamentales para la
reserva Federal el mercado laboral y la
demanda de productos por parte de los
consumidores resiste bien a la fuerte
subida de los tipos de interés y a la
alta inflación lo que da a los
responsables de la política monetaria en
ese país razones para continuar con sus
agresivas su vida de los tipos de
interés el gasto en general se ha
ralentizado y está cada vez más
orientado hacia las necesidades como los
alimentos Mientras que el gasto en
electrónica muebles ropa nueva y otros
artículos no necesarios ha caído
bastante el gasto de los consumidores
representa casi el 70% de toda la
actividad económica de Estados Unidos sí
Jorge y continuamos en Estados Unidos
porque el presidente de jobiden
consiguió llegar a un consenso entre el
sector ferroviario y los sindicatos para
evitar esa temida huelga Aunque algunos
sindicatos todavía que piden mejores
condiciones de trabajo aún no han
ratificado este acuerdo hasta ahora los
trabajadores acordaron no ir a la huelga
mientras se cuenten con los votos en las
próximas semanas editando un paro que
podría haber comenzado el viernes evitar
una huelga ayuda a la administración de
Joe biden a no lidiar con una nueva
escasez en la cadena de suministro y un
aumento de la antes de las elecciones de
noviembre ahora si los trabajadores
aceptan el trato obtendrán aumentos de
dos dígitos y se les va a permitir
Buscar ciertos tipos de atención médica
Sin temor a ser castigados esto luego de
tres años sin recibir un aumento de
sueldo en el marco de la disputa
contractual seguimos hablando con sobre
Estados Unidos y su impacto Obviamente
que tienen otras economías en
latinoamericanas por ejemplo en el caso
de México el Banco Central advirtió
sobre los riesgos que puede tener la
desaceleración de la uno en americana
otro factor que menciona también el
banco mexicano es el tratado de libre
comercio entre Estados Unidos Canadá
algunos conflictos que existen en este
tratado el banco público el reporte
sobre las economías regionales abril
junio 2022 donde destaca una posible
desaceleración de la economía de Estados
Unidos que podría afectar mediante un
menor dinamismo en las exportaciones o
en las remesas el emisor alertó de que
la caída del mercado laboral en Estados
Unidos podría disminuir el dinamismo que
ha venido exhibiendo el flujo de Reme
hacia México afectando principalmente el
consumo de los hogares que son
receptores otro de los temores de el
banco mexicano son las condiciones de
seguridad pública ya que esto podría
influir negativamente en la actividad
económica cambiamos de tema porque
Naciones Unidas está advirtiendo que hay
70 millones de personas que podrían
hacer en riesgo de hambruna en la guerra
en Ucrania lo dijo David del programa
mundial de alimentos de Naciones Unidas
según el funcionario Naciones Unidas
ahora cuenta con 345 millones de
personas que se acercan a lambruna en 45
países de todo el mundo esto porque la
guerra afecta a las exportaciones de
grano de Ucrania y las exportaciones de
fertilizantes de Rusia que son bastante
necesarios para producir alimentos
tomando en cuenta que Rusia y Ucrania
son actores claves en la producción
mundial de alimentos escuchemos que si
el funcionario del programa mundial de
elementos
una emergencia mundial de una magnitud
sin precedentes con La amenaza de una
hambruna masiva que crece sin cesar Al
comenzar el año 2022 nos enfrentamos a
una Tormenta perfecta debido al aumento
de los conflictos los efectos económicos
del covid el cambio climático y el
aumento de los precios de los
combustibles Y entonces justo cuando
crees que no puede ser peor Ucrania
y desde que comenzó este conflicto el
aumento de Los costos de los alimentos
El combustible y los fertilizantes ha
llevado a otros 70 millones de personas
al borde de la hambruna lo que era una
ola de hambre es ahora un tsunami de
hambre
importante cifra Jorge vamos con la
cifra del día precisamente otra cifra
espectacular 20.000 millones de dólares
eso costó la adquisición de figma por
parte de adobe las acciones de adobe
cayeron un 17% tras la compra firma fue
fundada en 2012 crea un software de
diseño basado en la nube que permite a
los equipos colaborar en tiempo real
pero compite directamente con el
programa XD Adobe figma era un dolor de
cabeza para adoba antes de la compra
porque es más barato Es más fácil de
usar es colaborativo y sobre todo
bastante moderno Jorge Hurtado con la
información económica Muchas gracias